so you do something with greeting cards
is that something you do from your spare
room nick jenkins former ceo and founder
of moon pig a company now worth 1.6
billion dollars my first proper business
was moon big which although it's been a
success of course it went through
various ups and downs like all overnight
successes it took 11 years i got to
confess i probably slightly stumbled on
it i look at it now and think wow that
accidentally was a really good business
model
unfortunately we too often we measure
the things that are easiest to measure
and the easiest thing to measure is how
wealthy someone is i'm reluctant to
create this illusion that that you know
if you work incredibly hard you can make
a lot of money and that will make you
successful you have to be a successful
human being the most exciting times i
ever had in my business were when my
back was absolutely against the one
thing this is going down bizarrely i
found that quite invigorating but at one
point my shells all said look nick this
is never gonna work it's never gonna
make money by the time i got to the end
of it i was pretty much down to zero
[Music]
nick jenkins former ceo and founder of
moonpig a company now worth 1.6 billion
dollars nick's achievements are
miraculous he's incredibly inspiring and
he created a business that's touched
many of our lives but the thing that i
found even more intriguing about nick
was he bucks most of the typical
entrepreneurship and success narratives
i think we're all sold the belief and
the story that in order to be successful
in business or any discipline in life
you have to undergo tremendous sacrifice
you have to work yourself into the
ground nick and his story and his
philosophy disprove all of that
he's got another way of doing it if
listening to this episode does anything
outside of just inspiring the hell out
of you and giving you very practical
business information it will definitely
prove
in my view that there is no such thing
as a born entrepreneur and also once you
become an entrepreneur the path to
success isn't the same for everybody
a lot of what you've been told is a lie
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire of a ceo i hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
nick
super intrigued when i meet
entrepreneurs um because there's
a huge sort of narrative and i guess a
debate that's happened in the
entrepreneurial community about whether
entrepreneurs are
made whether they're born whether it's
something that can be taught and
um from listening to you describe your
early years and your school years and
your upbringing um
i wondered what your opinion on that was
and also whether you think you were born
on japan
i think there are some traits that are
common to all entrepreneurs well one of
those is decisiveness you've got to be
able to take decisions and when i after
i worked in russia for a bit went and
did an mba and when i was there there
were lots of people on that course who
were brighter than me um but and they
would come up with a beautiful
powerpoint presentation of five
different choices of strategic options
but actually sometimes he's just got to
say i haven't got the perfect knowledge
let's go with that one and take a
decision and so i think decisiveness is
a very and really an attitude to risk is
is the other thing i think i always took
the view that you know i started with
nothing i could end up with nothing
and i it i wasn't that worried about
about failing um
and that's quite important and so so i
think those sort of things are are
innate you can teach someone like that
to be a better entrepreneur and to some
extent i mean i i went off and said the
business i had nothing else to do to be
honest at the time i came back from
russia and i had a spare year and i
thought i couldn't think of a good
cunning business plan so i'll do an mba
while i'm coming up with a cunning plan
and that that was that probably
made my first business a bit better
because i i gave me more of an idea of
the rounded idea of business and
um and and so on so so i think you can
improve on that but i don't think but if
you're if you're risk-averse you're not
going to do it where does where does
decisiveness and um that risk appetite
come from do you think in people and
what i guess where does the alternative
come from where does the fear
um and the lack of willingness to
to make a decision come from in people
or in you like where did it where did
that decision come from in you i don't
know you have some people who are
physically courageous they will leap in
you know rugby players will leap in and
do things and and other people who who
are not and then you have some people
who are
intellectually courageous who will just
um
they're just not afraid of saying
let's do it um um no i'm not i'm i'm not
sure but i think i think it comes from
not having a fear of a fear of failure
or not you know we're all going to make
mistakes and things will go wrong but
but uh if you're frightened of ever
making a mistake
um then then then you won't do it much
times like if you if you ski and you're
frightened of falling over you're never
going to be a great skier so you aren't
going to fall over you it's quite also
you were just talking about almost that
mental assessment you made on what
failure meant because you were like well
if i go to zero that's okay yeah that
doesn't mean death no no no no it
doesn't i mean it wouldn't be great you
know but but but it's survival and i and
i've of all the friends i've seen who've
gone through that and i've had a lot of
friends who've gone through uh who've
gone through business failures the ones
i admire the most are the ones who it's
the way they've dealt with that and some
of them have thought well i can't change
that i can't so all i can do is change
the way i approach the next step and
move on and if you just dwell on
failure what does that mean how does
that reflect on me um then
uh then you'd never
yeah you you'd never move on so
i think it's our own in our own attitude
to failure that's that's quite important
what was your underlying drive to even
start a business versus just going and
getting a job at i don't know pizza hut
or something
i suppose i probably looked at that and
thought if that goes well i'll probably
make more money per hour than if i go
and work with pizza so there's an
element of one want to i mean maybe
there's an element of laziness that
comes into this it's wanting to take
that shortcut and think well well
actually if i if i start my own business
and and that goes
and it goes well then
obviously
it's it's better than an hourly paid job
one of my great philosophies on business
is just keep everything as simple as you
can possibly make it until you have to
make it more complicated
um people often start they start you
know way too complicated and and and uh
over-engineer things that you if you
read that book the lean startup it kind
of talks talks to some of those values
about just trying to is find find the
simplest way to test the hypothesis as
cheaply as you can without using losing
years of your life and there's nothing
there's nothing quite like not actually
having any money to do that so when the
moon pig when when we we raised money on
a very bitty basis you know there was
never like a well that occasionally
would pour something in it and you know
you you you hear it hitting the bottom
but it never actually filled the well up
so we never really have much money to
experiment with so we had to be uh
very lean with what we did and i think
perhaps the one the one useful thing the
only textbook that i ever went back to
from my mba years was a statistics uh
textbook because what i wanted to work
out is the least money i could spend to
get a statistically significant answer
to how much a cost to customer
acquisition is for a particular channel
because why spend two and a half why
spend 25 000 pounds finding out that a
particular channel doesn't work for you
when you can get the answer for two and
a half thousand um and uh you must see
this all the time but i i you get people
who say we're going to spend a million
pounds on our when you've got too much
money you just let's throw some money at
this and see what works well why waste
it when you can get the answer for two
and a half grand yeah and then and then
and then and i always look at that and i
don't think i don't think i've wasted
two and a half grand i've spent two and
a half grand some of that will have been
let's say i was aiming for a 10-pound
cost of customer acquisition and and
actually it was 20. well then 1 250
pounds of that was spent on acquiring
customers at the right price and 1 250
pounds was spent on finding out that i
should never do that again
and that's that's the way i would look
at that but if i spent 25 000 pounds on
it yeah then you know it would have been
it would have been a waste and also if
you can the more
you spend money to find out the answers
to things and when you've got those
answers and you're then putting that in
your business plan to raise money i'm
always more impressed when people say
right i want to raise money for
marketing this is what we've done so far
this is what it cost us so far so if we
scale this up that's that's what we can
do as opposed to just saying
please give us lots of money to spend on
marketing we don't know what we're going
to do yet um yeah i had this
conversation actually with my gym owner
the other day i didn't even know that he
was um aware of who i was but i was
leaving the gym he goes can i just have
two minutes pulls me into the back room
and um he tells me about this idea and
to be fair i can't say the idea because
he and we're going to talk about this
topic as well he thinks that if you tell
the idea then i'm going to run off with
it we'll talk about that
all the time yeah we'll talk about that
straight after but um but but so it's
idea for rolling out gyms in the country
he said i need to i need to raise
investment to put 10 of them in and i
was like
your this idea you have is totally
contingent on this central hypothesis
i'm just going to say he doesn't podcast
that um
people that drive long haul want to work
out in service stations yeah you don't
need to put 10 in to figure out if that
hypothesis is correct you can put a
shipping container in the car park
keep it there for free and if anyone
picks up the dumbbells that's that's an
indication that your hypothesis is
correct and then introduce another
variable which is cost yeah so then
charge them to pick up the dumbbells and
if you if you come back to me
in six months time and say steve they
picked up the dumbbells they worked out
and they gave me 10 pounds a month then
all you need is capital yeah and we'll
go make ten of them yeah yeah we're on
the same page
you know i'll prove what you can prove
on the least amount of money first and
evidence is evidence is always so
important um
and people miss that but let's talk
about that topic then so this idea of it
really really it shows me that the
entrepreneur is somewhat naive when an
entrepreneur comes up i'm sure you get
this all the time they picture an idea
and then they say
well they sound cagey to tell you the
full thing because they think you're
going to run off and do it yeah yeah
yeah
when i would say to them look if you get
the the day you go live with that the
moment you start advertising that idea
you're you're opening you're lifting
your skirts to the whole world so uh so
you're gonna have to go live with us at
some point otherwise you're not going to
sell anything and if you don't sell
anything you're going to raise any money
from anybody so at some point you have
to
uh you you have to tell people what
you're doing with moon pig there was no
way that i could i could protect that
idea the only way you can protect it is
be the best and and and be the biggest
amen yeah
i mean and then i we had probably 20
competitors that followed after moon pig
you know during our time then they would
they'd pop up and they'd flare up and
then they'd die off again um and and
even now moon pig is 65 to the market
when you started moon pig was there
anyone else doing personalized um sort
of gifting cards online yeah funny
enough that there was there was a very i
came up with a business plan and i
developed it and then i looked the first
thing i always do is i look around not
just at what direct competitors i've got
but how people are trying to solve that
problem in other ways because you know
if you're trying to solve a problem
clearly that problem exists already and
people are trying to solve it in one way
or another and and i did come across a
company that was doing um
personalized greeting cards
and and i approached them and said oh
i've got a choice i can either i've come
up with this plan i can either do it
myself or i can invest in your business
and um and
and anyway he the terms he offered were
ridiculous and also the other problem
was i could see that is we would we were
going to fall out over the content of
the cards because um
i just didn't think he had a very good
eye for cards um without that business
anything ever turned over more than 300
000 a year
and then it died about two years later
um and uh and moon pig went so i i went
off and did my own thing and what it
taught me actually looking back at it is
that is that it was all about the
content it was about the quality of the
of the cars the quality of the design of
the cars because actually the customer
doesn't really care how the car was
produced they didn't care about the
technology at all what they want is the
end product and and we have the best end
product that's so interesting because um
a lot of entrepreneurs are put off from
starting an idea because when they
google their idea that they have they
find 10 of the people that are already
doing it and i i really want to touch on
this point because i think it's quite
liberating for entrepreneurs listening
when i started my business in fact every
business i've ever started that's been
successful had a major
incumbent already and we might we became
the biggest and it's exactly what you
described it's those there's probably a
thousand small details that go into
making a successful bit listen more
let's just say there's a thousand yeah
thousands more details like into making
your business and it's and um you're
basically going to war on a thousand
details yeah and if you can um
you know if you can be better in just
certain ways and sometimes you only need
to be better in a few simple ways
i think it can i i agree and but then
then
if you look at the example of bread um
people have been eating bread for
thousands of years you know people like
bread we know what people prefer to pay
for bread that's half of your market
research done already you don't have to
say we've got something called bread do
you do you like it you can you can get
some slices you just ham in the middle
and call it a sandwich
all that's been done for you so then
you've then got to work out right well i
know i know that there's a market for
this so how do i just make it a little
bit a little bit better do i make it as
a you know add seeds to it do i put
cumin in it do i or do i have a shop
that is in a location where that isn't
well served so you only have to tweak an
idea that's already there so your chance
of success your chance of succeeding
your chance of surviving is considerably
greater because you've answered most of
the questions already before you've even
invested any money um the chance of that
becoming the chance of multiplying by a
factor of a thousand and suddenly
thinking that's like the guy in shortage
has just invented stuff called bread
it's amazing never had it before um so
you don't get that and i think that's an
important thing for entrepreneurs to
think about is that you don't have to be
unique i think that's you know people
always are what's what's unique about
you just got to be i agree with you
you've got to be better in some respect
and um and people tie themselves in
knots trying to think of trying to
invent things so i think it's a really
hard it's the hardest possible way of
making money i mean actually when you i
i read a report about the fact that the
the people who've most people who've
made money have made money doing
something they were previously employed
to do
because because they've spent 20 years
learning how to do something they know
all the contacts and then they start up
their own business it's logical not you
know when i'm looking at investing in
people i think well you know this
industry really really well you're very
convincing um and and you you know all
the pitfalls in advance perhaps of
course you're more likely to succeed
yeah but they also know they also
because they know the pitfalls they know
that where the opportunity to create a
better product would be as well yeah
yeah you know because so often i will i
will come up with a business idea and
look at it and it's only after i've gone
through this sort of fourth iteration of
the business brand that i think
and that is why no one has done this
before
that's very very true um
if you'd known how hard it would be
um to start a business and to
um make it successful do you think you
would have started because i'm here i'm
asking i want to know a little bit about
the like the importance of delusion
well funny if that's something i've
always believed that an element of
self-delusion is very very important and
i think that's one of the reasons why
actually
when i i when i finished my b i did have
the opportunity to go and join a vc firm
i thought i could if i can work for vc
firm for three or four years i'll get
more experience before i start my own
business anyway i went for a job
interview shock horror they turned me
down so i had to go and start my own
business and and i realized now that if
i had gone through several years of
investing in other people's businesses i
probably would have developed that kind
of
uh that hard skin of of this is actually
incredibly hard but this is why this
won't work and i see that
i see that a lot now in me now that i
look at as an investor i look at a lot
of things and i'm
i'm less wide-eyed than i was when i
started moon pig and i can see the
reasons why something won't work and you
become you can become too cynical about
it
whereas when i started moon pig if i'd
known all the problems that i was going
to come up against i may not have
started it and believe me there were
plenty of times in the middle of that uh
when i would have happily given it up i
mean people often say whether was there
a difficult period and they said there
was just one but it lasted from 2000 to
2005. um and and it was
[Music]
that was difficult it was it was tough
and i was wondering how to pay the
salaries and i'd talk to me about the
detail of that difficult period well
as as as you know better than anybody
that starting a business is one thing
and coming up with a product that people
might want is one thing getting
customers is probably the single most
difficult thing about setting up any
online business um and i think most
people underestimate that and we we
tried all sorts of permutations and bear
in mind this was 2000 so this was well
before social media so a lot of stuff
was very manual um i you know you will
laugh at this but when i was when i was
doing affiliate deals i would phone up a
company and say we'll put an advert on
your thing and if you send any traffic
to us we'll give you a bit of commission
on this and i'll send you a spreadsheet
every week to tell you how much i owe
you literally it was that manual and i
would write up a contract for each
separate contract for each individual
company had a big filing cabinet of them
i mean this you know that sounds like
very dinosaurish but that's how it was
and now it's it's much much easier um
but we were
we were struggling to find ways ways
that we could throw money at driving
traffic because everything that we threw
money at was too expensive and the only
thing that was really working in all of
this was the viral effect that we knew
that
we were we got very very good at
measuring everything and and we could
see that if we brought 100 customers in
that and those 100 customers we knew
exactly how many them would buy cards we
knew how many of them wouldn't come back
again but of the ones that bought cards
we knew that they would attract about
for every customer
that we had they'd attract a third of a
customer just because i send you a
birthday card you think it's funny you
look on the back of it moonpig.com and
so that viral effect was the thing that
kept us going for five years and it was
only really because i understood the
statistics behind that and i could
understand the model and think right
although everything else appears to be
failing although this online campaign
doesn't appear to be too expensive that
appears to be too expensive and we we
can't i couldn't tell you if someone
gave me 10 million pounds i couldn't
have told you what we could have thrown
it at um to make it work i could see
that just the customers alone were
driving the sales growth and if only we
could survive that long that we would we
would make it through um but i was the
only person who believed that all of my
shareholders at one point my shells all
said look nick you know it's not going
to work this is never going to work it's
never going to make money and you you
know we're not going to put more money
in and we really recommend that you
don't put any more money in too because
when this all goes wrong you're going to
have to have some money to pay the rent
and and it was it was that bad um how
much did you had you bet on this
personally well i mean i put in i was i
i'd gone off and worked in russia for a
while and i probably made about a
million and and by the time
uh by the time i i put about 150 000
pounds into mubic at the beginning to
get the idea off the ground
by the time i got to the end of it um i
i was pretty much down to zero i think
i'd taken all the equity out of the flat
which previously had no mortgage i'd
taken all my savings and all that so i
pretty much got down to zero
so at the point where people are trying
to discourage you to
i was pretty much already at zero zero
anyway so so and that that's when it's
that's when finally it started to turn
and um you know but i could i could see
i could see the stats i could see where
it was going
um it's just that you know after four
years of
i've had three or four different
business plans you know i know the last
business plan wasn't you know inaccurate
but this one this one's better oh and i
know the previous two weren't that
accurate but this one this one this one
works yeah
it's tough that's that delusion did you
ever genuinely consider quitting
no no i didn't know because that big
because i because i could see where the
numbers were going and i had i did have
a firm belief that uh the repeat rate
was there um the viral effect was there
and i could see how i could see how we
weren't spending we went through a year
we spent no money on marketing
whatsoever no money on customer
acquisition and we and our sales grew by
30 percent
you know so that's now i appreciate
having invested in lots of other
e-commerce businesses i appreciate how
unusual that is um it was my first
business so i didn't know quite how
unusual it was but but i knew that
actually look it's not as if there's so
many businesses i see now that the
moment you turn the marketing tap off
yeah just goes to zero yeah and all you
and
and that's one of the things i'm always
really aware of when i'm aware of now
when i'm investing is when is it i said
well what what's going to happen when
you turn that money to turn that tap off
because because when we did turn that
tap off it just kept on growing and
that's what i see is the real quality of
a business is when you're adding layer
upon layer of customers now you know not
all businesses are as good at repeat
business as moon pig was but but that
was that that was the the thing that i
recognized that kept me going through
all that and stopped me from throwing
the towel in and that's thankfully
because you had a great product
underpinning
yeah
the the main focus was was do people do
people like what we're selling um and we
knew that we knew it's a very very
popular product we could see that in the
viral effect with people not only do
people who bought it liked it but the
people who received it liked it so
the main focus was always on
create a really really good product and
then of course on top of that you then
got to make sure that you've got your
production right so that your gross
margins are right and and you're
tweaking all of those little knobs
within within within that uh engine um
and um
and the the key thing also just is
understanding um is understanding every
every metric and we looked at like it's
like a lose run that you're polishing um
every day you're looking at is there is
there anywhere where anyone's getting
stuck along this journey and and are
they not understanding what we're you
know the button that they're supposed to
press next are they getting confused in
which polish that one out so there was a
constant process that that time when we
weren't spending any money on customer
acquisition we were spending all of our
money on uh on customer retention and
just polishing that lose run
of the customer coming in through the
front door and going into the shopping
basket when you reflect on that and the
the fact that moonpig ultimately
succeeded in a market where many others
failed you talked about you know the guy
that you whose business you tried to buy
and you say what was it about what we
did that made us succeed or what was it
about me
nick that made this business succeed
what is your answer well i think i think
i probably did have a good understanding
of what people wanted in a card
and the if you get down to the
the simplest version of that is that is
that a card is about showing someone
that you've uh you want to show them
that you've that it's relevant you've
thought about them so you've chosen
something which is relevant to them that
they're interested in or that's that's a
something you both find funny
and you can weave their name into that
as well um to make to show that you've
made an effort and then the double
whammy i would always personalize moon
picard have it sent back to me and write
on the inside so that's like a double
personalization and it's it it basically
is about showing you've really thought
about them and that's and and and it's
amusing as well and and the the great
thing is quirky british sense of humor
that we we love slightly mildly
offending each other and then we we
stick the cards up in our fridge
so
if you focus on that focus on the on on
the product everything else everything
else follows in behind that focus on the
product and then make it very very
efficient um and uh and everything else
should follow whereas whereas if you
don't focus on the product and you're
just constantly selling something that
people don't really want it's incredibly
hard work
on the product a lot of people have this
idea i think when they start businesses
that you have to have your hypothesis
your idea of what this business is going
to become the product of yourself
perfectly nailed before you um before
you launch and then you know i made the
mistake of when i started my business
kind of being too romantic about that
initial idea so i was trying to force
the idea into the world as opposed to
listening um if we'd go back before you
started moon pig
what what was your hypothesis like what
in terms of like personalization what
you know how did you arrive at a card it
was it was very simple actually i i
thought through the different ideas and
i and and i realized right the this
internet thing is is going to happen so
i don't know much about it but no one
else knows anything about it either but
i did at least understand how to build a
team so i spent 10 years in russia
building a team of people and building a
successful business um and
and i went through this thing of what
things could i what how can i use the
internet to make a business and digital
digital products were all being given
away for free so everyone had this idea
that if you could download it it ought
to be free well that's a hard one to
make money in
the advertising business back in those
days was incredibly tough because there
wasn't much of a market
not much spend was going online and you
were spending more money to get people
to come to your site to look at the
adverts and people are going to pay you
for the adverts that was tough too
then i looked at physical goods and if
you take say a digital camera one of
those things i looked at if i took my
sort of satsuma fujitsu 32db i figured
that somebody at some point would write
an algorithm that would merely compare
the price of my fujitsu 32dd with
someone else's and then they'd buy the
cheapest one and that ultimately would
end up squeezing all the margin out of
that game so you'd end up with a lot of
physical stocks stuffed
sitting in warehouses and minimal
margins so so i looked at one of the
things that i can what are the things i
can sell on the internet where i can
actually improve the product make it
better and personalization is one of
those things it's very difficult to do
personalization in store because it
takes up floor space and equipment and
so on um and um
and i thought of a number of different
things including uh personalized cds
well i'm really really glad i didn't do
that one and
cards occur to me because i used to um i
used to typically buy cards and tips out
the caption and write something a bit
funnier um more relevant and more
relevant on the front and and and
equally journalist friends of mine would
uh whenever anyone left the office
they'd be given a spoof magazine front
cover which would take a day and a half
of graphic design time to put together
and i and i figured
we got digital digital printing was
beginning to develop at the time and you
got the internet and it made it possible
to combine those two to make it possible
for someone to order a single
personalized greeting card which has got
hands down got to be better than the
unpersonalized thing and then i could
charge more for the product online than
for the product in the shop but more to
the point there's no stock
so um so what we've got is a pile of
cardboard in the corner of the room and
a pile of envelopes that's the only
stock which i think represented about a
quarter of a percent of turnover so
compared to the digital camera business
where you might have a whole load of
digital cameras on the water coming in
from wherever you buy them from loading
the warehouse and so on um it's it was
um it was a very efficient business
model i mean
i i gotta confess i probably slightly
stumbled on it rather than you know it
it being
i look at it now and think wow that that
accidentally was a really good business
model um you get paid up front you pay
supplies in 60 days there's no stock i
mean it's it's uh it was great
so um
but but fundamentally it was a better
product and on day one right from the
very beginning my
the business plan i came up with when i
was doing my mba was i want to to make
it possible for a customer to buy a
single personalized birthday card which
technology has suddenly made possible
whereas previously that would have been
200 quids worth of graphic design time a
bit of lie through i mean just not
possible but core to that
is that the person who's receiving it
has got to think that's a really cool
card
and there was a point where you made the
decision to sort of step back from
operations
i i've always tried to my general
approach this is uh is
try to focus on the things that only you
can do
um and
when you really narrow it down and you
become a bigger company you realize that
actually
that really does narrow it down a lot
because i was trying to hire people
replace the things that i was doing with
people who could do it better than i
could do it uh and then once they're
doing it better than i could do you
think gosh well i'm not going to
interfere with that anymore so leave
them to it and then it eventually then
comes down to um
uh to a role i i
my role eventually that became that of
executive chairman so i
brought in a ceo and i became executive
chairman and i suppose then my role was
that strategic role of making sure that
we're we're pointing in the right
direction and also that we take those
big decisions
what are you bad at
i'm i'm or not good not as good as
someone else's actually say
i i think i'm i'm a i'm good at
short-term detail i can i can sprint on
real fine detail um so i can i can sit
on a spreadsheet for six hours overnight
and come up with a beautiful bit of
financial modelling but i i've got a
million one things going on and and so
so so i don't know that i'm necessarily
a complete a finisher um and there are
people who are good at that so
interesting when i'm looking at hiring
people i i will often although
um i
academic results aren't everything
that you always need someone who has got
straight a's at a level because
they're very good at understanding the
question and delivering it delivering
the answer so they understand what's
expected of them and they deliver it in
a very predictable way
whereas
ceos can often be quite maverick and you
ask them one question and they will
answer something else completely
different but much more interesting
and that's fine you can afford to have
one or two of those mavericks but
somebody in the company has to be a good
completer finisher um they understand
the question and they deliver it have
you this is interesting so there's
certain people in my in my in my
previous business where i knew they were
like useless at organization and process
and they were they were just dread they
could they were like unreliable
but they had one skill which was genius
yeah and so it would almost be like
making an
exception for them within the company
where okay they might take a long time
to reply to emails and stuff like that
but that one point of like creative
genius that they brought to the company
was worth it yeah did you ever have that
very definitely you've got you've got
some people
i think creative genius always comes at
a price yeah
and and it becomes because someone has
focused on one thing at the expense of
something else generally um
and
and so you just have to work with it um
and and say right okay well that's
recognized person doesn't do that and
actually those skills can easily be
dealt with by something else that get
them a good
pa someone who can organ get a good
complete finisher behind them who picks
up after them and and and then they will
come up with the ideas that nobody else
would have come up with yeah i think
that works
you know i hate i hate
powder i hate mixing powder with water i
hate protein powders that you have to
mix with water
up until now and
obviously he'll sponsor this podcast so
i'm tremendously biased but that's a
that's a true story i've never been able
to use the like my protein powders that
you mix with water because i always
think they taste absolutely awful
up until hull released their brand new
protein flavor the amazing thing about
all of these proteins is there's 20
grams of protein you get all of your
vitamins and nutrients 26 of those and
as huel always is it's nutritionally
complete
and if you are someone that's trying to
go a little bit lower on the calories
it's only 105 calories so when i wake up
in the morning especially i've been
working out a lot lately come downstairs
quickly blend it together in my
nutribullet
drink it's 100 calories and then my next
sort of main meal because i'm a
breakfast skipper will be
at lunchtime highly recommend it um and
i shouldn't say this because i don't
have any approval to say this but
there's some amazing amazing flavors
coming in the ready to drink range that
i've been lucky enough to try
um
and
one of those is my new favorite flavor
so stay tuned you were talking about
that struggle you had for the first five
years of music specific i heard you
talking some interviews about you know
three four five etcetera being
particularly hard but um
what was what was the personal
sacrifice of that i'm thinking now about
how easy it was to maintain like
relationships and friendships when
you know in your head you probably have
that red
read those red numbers from the
management accounts and sort of etched
into your mind at all times can't be
honest never really got in the way
that never got in the way
no no i
i'm a lot of people confuse um that's
all we're running your own business
you're working all the hours at godsends
um i never did if something needs to be
done i could i if and only i could do it
then i would do it and there were time
you know there's the odd time when uh i
remember once when our entire printing
team uh uh
were off ill and
i came back from a business trip to
australia for most from australia to
discover that we were three three days
behind on on our printing schedule and i
simply i simply got in the printing room
i was the only other person qualified to
use the printer so i just sat in the
printing room and i worked uh
24 hours a day for two for three days i
think to get it all done so yes there
were times but but i had a great social
life i've always been a great believer
also that that i i need to i like to
manage a business
you know during reasonable hours i don't
i don't think it's important that people
need to sacrifice themselves on the
altar of my business and i don't like
them doing that one because it makes me
feel guilty about skyping off um you
know if you've got all of your whole of
your people in the office and they're
they're working 24 hours a day and and
you're sort of you know taking half the
day off to go and do something fun
i
feel awful um so
so i try to make sure the same standards
apply and and
and that people should people should
work a proper you know proper day's work
in the hours that they would
like to work within reason um but i do
expect them to go off and go and do
something different and recharge their
batteries in the evening and the
weekends and
you know because otherwise you just run
out of steam and particularly it was a
creative business you know we're
trying to make people laugh if you're
exhausted and miserable um
um that's tough
it goes against a lot of the sort of
typical narrative doesn't it in
entrepreneurship like the hustle porn
star entrepreneur who just like back in
doesn't sleep and
just caffeine and just you know they're
like crying in the street
like
and they're like you know eating ramen
noodles and stuff like that what does
that what does that narrative make you
uh make you think
well i think that's true if you start a
business with a lot of people start a
business with nothing and a lot of
businesses fail and and as those
businesses are failing clearly obviously
you're down to your last pennies and
that's tough and and and so i think that
the thing that they're describing is
that is the last sort of death throes of
a business and i you know i've seen lots
of businesses that i've invested in go
through the same thing where there is no
money left you can't pay salaries uh and
the the founders are down to uh you know
they're living in the office um under
the desk and and exactly eating noodles
uh and and
so that happens um
but
it but it is it isn't it isn't an
essential part of the journey but
generally the death rows
and occasionally you survive i mean you
know i had i not had had i not had that
last bit of cash that i put in i i may
well have been one of those cases um
what about focus a lot of entrepreneurs
you know have
i get a lot of messages from
entrepreneurs that have multiple
businesses
three or four startups they're doing at
the same time well i wouldn't invest in
anybody that had multiple startups
but what way you know because if i'd had
three businesses going at the same time
as a moon thinking was going badly you
you focus on the one that's going well
because it makes you feel better so
i
and then the person then they then they
turn around to the investors who put
money into the third one and they say
i'm yeah and i've given up with that one
i'm off to so there is no way i mean
when i invest in a business i would make
sure that there's a clause that says
that the foundation the founder
shareholders have to be 100 focused on
that they're not allowed to have more
than a four five percent stake in
another unlimited company i'm pretty
strict about that yeah i i mean i just
think it's laughable yeah absolutely
laughable that people come along and
they get you i've got three ideas and
i'd like you to invest in this one
but i've got those just in case that one
doesn't work yeah
for me it's for me as well i i tend to
think all three will fail because you're
giving like 30 in my way that i've even
if you're not prioritizing you're giving
33
of your time and energy
and all your competitors are giving 101
and a lot of them might be sleeping
under the desk so if you're giving 30
you're it's already hard enough to
succeed giving 100
yeah so you're really setting yourself
up to failure but i think there's this
weird thing where entrepreneurs find it
impressive
to some some entrepreneurs find it
impressive to list multiple businesses
that they're doing and i swear if i hear
an entrepreneur come to me with an idea
and they've also got another thing
they're doing i'm immediately deeply
unimpressed by them because i think
they've got this focus problem um
and maybe they're you know like maybe
they sat down and
tried to think of a business idea and
for me like when business ideas don't
come from some type of inspiration when
they're literally just contrived from
i'm going to try and think of a business
idea
i think that it's typically more
difficult i think like some form of
inspiration even if it's a small thing
of inspiration as a it's integral to
success
and creating something unique um
but yeah that's another thing that
irritates me about
i i i i get just as irritated by that
the times when you have to push on
through that barrier and if you've got
three things going
and one of them is an easier journey
that's where you're going to focus
yourself when in fact the that is the
absolute time that you need to be
completely focused on on on crashing
through that wall that you've come up
against
and and that's where
the best inspiration i ever had and
sometimes actually
looking back the most exciting times i
ever had in my business were when my
back was absolutely against the one
thing this is going down this is going
down and bizarrely i found that quite
invigorating
um when everything is going incredibly
well
there were times when i think
everything's going very well everyone's
doing their job frankly i could be here
and not be here it doesn't make much
difference um
in terms of skills as well as an
entrepreneur you i heard you talk about
public speaking being integral to
you did public speaking at university i
did i did a lot of public speaking at
university and a lot of debating and
the skill i think that's important is
the ability to be able to persuade
people of your ideas not necessarily
public speaking but in every meeting
that you go to you need to be able to
look people in the eye and convince them
that your idea is right and and that
could be in a sales role it could be
sitting around a table with a bunch of
developers and one of them saying i
think this is the right way forward if
you can't articulate yourself properly
then you're never going to be listened
to and that's a skill that i think is is
um
uh it's being recognized in schools i do
a lot in education now so i i see now
more and more they recognize that that's
a skill that is
really important that people should be
able to look someone in the eye and be
able to explain yourself very very
coherently i i tend to actually believe
i'd go one step further and think i
can't think of a more important skill in
life and business then we i call i refer
to it as sales because and we think of
sales we think of trying to get cash out
of someone else's pocket by giving them
something but i think if it was like
meet a girl in a nightclub you know try
and communicate your idea to your team
investors employees um everyone you
encounter i think is a to some degree
you're trying to sell something and it's
usually yourself yeah but and those that
are you think about how that compounds
over the over 70 years of your life
being good or bad at that one skill
will anything change the trajectory of
your life more than being like a good
sales person
and that comes from as you say from
being able to articulate yourself and
speak and
yeah and just think coherently and put
down
a logical argument that people think yes
okay i get that i understand it how does
one get better at that
i think a lot of that's practice
um and
i i think you know people make this uh
sort of binary thing between public
speaking standing on stage and speaking
to a crowd of people um versus not doing
anything at all and actually in between
there's a whole load of stuff which is
which is
working within a team and being able to
and that that's where most people come
up against it is that they'll be sitting
in a meeting with four or five other
people and they've got something they
want to say
and they
they if they're too nervous about saying
something they just don't say anything
at all and then their ideas are never
listened to yeah and then they're
devalued in that context and similarly
it may not necessarily be a spoken word
you've also got to be able to write well
and convincingly then there's another
side of it which is the numeracy side
and i find i find that the the most
convincing is when i went i i love a
good spreadsheet but uh but when you can
express ideas in in numbers and you say
look this is the model that works and
you can prove it in in numbers
it is it's a very convincing thing
particularly
yeah i think right if we do this this is
the evidence we've got
that's what will happen yeah that's very
convincing um so there's there's there's
also being numerous and being able to
explain things in numbers which
is yeah yeah it's so true yeah you can
be like orally persuasive which is you
know anecdotal persuasion i guess and
then you can be persuasive with numbers
which is uh or graphics and that's the
other thing i i do see the quality of
decks in the last 15 years has
dramatically improved um and
in that all that they're much much more
engaging and and there's some real
creative genius behind some of the stuff
i mean occasionally they don't talk
about the numbers which is
a beautiful beautiful peaceful
presentation and in a big sort of you
know you go through the the docs end and
it's all fantastic it looks lovely
beautiful graphics and then you think
you have kind of missed out the point
about how you're going to make any money
but so there's a lot more so again but
that comes down to how you persuade
people how you present how you present
ideas not all of us
not all of us understand things by
listening some people understand by
seeing i see patterns in numbers but not
everyone does and i i realize that now
that that just because i happen to see
something one way doesn't mean to say
that everybody else sees it in that way
and you have to understand how people
how people communicate one of the on
that point about you know persuasion and
communication um one of the most amazing
things that happened to me inadvertently
was um well one of them's right here i
started doing a podcast and i from i
never the unintended um consequence of
me
being forced to speak on stage because i
was running around the world talking
about marketing um and being forced to
write out and i do quotes on instagram
write these quotes every single day at 7
pm on instagram and then write i used to
write this podcast i used to just be on
my own um was that i a and was able to
develop my ideas better so if you ask me
any question marketing well i've already
written it out i've written written an
essay on it because i had to do a blog
because i had to wear my personal brand
or if you asked me something else about
my life i've already spent
you know a thousand hours talking on
this podcast about it was i became um
much i'd say 10x better at communicating
and the impact that i had on my life was
just profound so my conclusive point
here is i really think for young people
that there are ways to force yourself to
accelerate that learning yeah one of
them is like keep like you know
keep a blog yeah start a podcast even if
no one's listening to it
um
and i i i people will start podcasts
because they're trying to make money or
because they want to be famous or have
loads of followers but i but i think the
more beneficial thing
is the skill um
the skills you'll learn from doing it
and oh my god sales is just everything
to me yeah
you're right when you have to write a
blog actually write the words down it
really forces you to think about how to
express things coherently
in a way that
verbally you can get away with a lot
less discipline
dragon's done
something we share in common yes indeed
yeah i've just uh just started on the
show
um it was a yeah i mean
the first pitch everything walking in
behind the cell i mean i first watched
it when i was 12 years old
it was also surreal how was your
experience when dragons dragonstone
and what advice would you have for me
let's do the first question okay well so
my so i i love the experience um i mean
partly it because it's it's very
forgiving television to make in the
sense that uh you arrive on set apart
from the fact there are seven cameras
which was distracting for about the
first hour or two other than that it's
people walking through the door and
they're saying this is who i am this is
my business
and it's one of those things that i
think i think if you're
if you're thinking about that as a
potential career
it's about as realistic as you can get
while still being entertaining these are
these are real businesses that people
have spent sometimes several years
developing and put their life and soul
into it it's not some concocted thing
that um you know here's 100 pounds
go and see how much cheese you can sell
on the market at the type thing that you
see in the apprentice these are real
businesses and i think it's been very
inspiring i've seen a ground a real
shift in
the time that i've been around in
people's attitudes to becoming an
entrepreneur um because of yeah
partly but you know partly because i
think there's also been a shift in
attitude generally yeah and a lot of a
lot of young people aspire to the idea
that actually when you're young and
you've got nothing to lose
you can afford to make more mistakes so
rather than so you can just go straight
straight into it after after school
start something and
crash and burn start again and you can
do it all now from your phone as well
you know you can set up a shop
using shopify on your phone in a couple
of minutes and sell you know you can
even drop shop drop ship things so you
don't need a warehouse or anything like
that so it's very incredibly accessible
now yeah um more people young people
want to be entrepreneurs than ever
before but uh but but i i think it's it
i'm i'm really looking forward to seeing
uh and seeing this new series because i
think you will add a uh kind of a
different a different dimension to it in
terms of thinking particularly the way
that businesses now you know the way
that particularly tech businesses and
the way that they're funded
um is yeah it's very it's very different
from 20 years ago yeah
one of the things i didn't expect as
well was how useful the other dragons
are when it comes to analyzing the
business oh yeah yeah because they all
come from different disciplines so
deborah's going to help me with the
numbers over here and peter's got his
background in tech and you know
logistics and all the amazing things he
does and tuca's going to be able to
really sort of interrogate the supply
chain and sarah understands the craft
industry and business generally and um
so it was it's really uh they said
sometimes you just gotta let them
interrogate the business from all of
their angles i i learned a lot i learned
a very very important lesson from
deborah about um the food business and
going to supermarkets
she was interrogating somebody and and
talking about their gross margin and she
said well of course
as soon as your sales go up
your gross margin will go down i'm
thinking
what are you talking about
and then and i asked her about this
afterwards and she said well the problem
is that supermarkets love to have young
pioneer brands in uh and they
um and they will allow you to be on
their shelves so there's pyramid of
products and they allow you these little
innovative little companies to be to add
interest to their shelves the moment
that it looks interesting and you want
to sell more of it the supermarket is
aha now let's talk about the price
because they they know how to make that
stuff even better than you do they know
how to squeeze you down to a barely
acceptable margin and so your margin
which looked okay at the beginning and
they'll say well you can sell a lot more
but we're gonna have to have a different
price and that's and that was a lesson i
learned from deborah so so sitting back
and listening sometimes and and you know
like you know tuca's knowledge of supply
chain
and in textiles in particular it's quite
quite fascinating
so jumping back to your business then
moving so eventually you sell the
business yeah um fully or in part well i
sold i sold most of it in 2011 and i
rolled over
i rolled over into the venture capital
investment in the new in the new company
we basically merged two companies we
merged photo box and moon pick together
um with a lot of venture capital money
and and so i reinvested in that and then
we sold sold it all out in 2016.
um
so there's a couple of things here that
was the first point where you became
really rich
well
we moving started making a lot of money
before we sold oh right so we were
probably making about 10 million a year
in dividends um so
because it was making money faster
faster than we could spend it on
advertising so so so we just paid it out
as dividends i think
we paid out about 30 million pounds in
dividends before we sold oh wow so um
quite literally printing money so so by
the time i sold actually it wasn't as if
it was transformational because um
i i hadn't spent the money i i've still
got all the money that i'd taken out as
dividends so when when you so if you you
really built enough wealth to take care
of all of your sort of base basic maslow
over your needs clearly you know yeah so
when you when you sell
how how does that feel well it was funny
i i was i i was interviewed afterwards
and uh on sky i think and they said well
you know what are you gonna buy uh what
are you gonna do now
and i was like
what did you do immediately afterwards
and i thought well i cycled home and i
made a peanut butter and jam sandwich i
mean that was because
there was a
it's slightly
it's a bit of a weird anti-climax
selling i don't know how it was for you
but i went into a large room and i had
to sign about 200 documents um on my own
and then i sort of done it now and they
get a great well money have been banked
later on
back of the bike cycle home that was it
oh there was no sort of you know
no trumpets you know no signings shaking
hands it was it was um um quite a
non-event really so the money arrives
the same day when you've sold um yes
yeah well not not all of it i think it
was done it was done in stages but
mostly arrived on the same day yeah yeah
and so that you sold the company over a
100 million at the time yeah rolled
shares into the the holding company as
well um to keep it sort of invested in
an interest in the business
um
yeah i mean that's a that's a
[ __ ] ton of money did was there sort of
a loss in because you've given up your
your business here you've given up your
focus yeah your baby was there a bit of
a lot like a loss of orientation like
what do i do now with my life
yes though at the same time i think i
got to a point where i delegated
everything within the company and i had
been largely focused on the sale process
for a year or so so after that sales
process was over you think well
now the day-to-day running of this
business has been left to uh the the
team they're all doing a fantastic job
they're all bright and they're probably
better than i am
so me sticking around in that kind of if
i decided to carry on running the
business for profit i could have done
but i but i i felt as though i'd run my
course i felt as i added everything i
could add to that business and there
were lots of other things i wanted to do
in life um so
um
in a way it was
it was a challenge to sort of create an
identity outside of that you know
because for a long time i've been missed
a rusher i'd gone to russia and everyone
knew me as the person who went to russia
and did things in russia and then i did
as i started moving i fell into
obscurity again people think oh poor
nicki does something with greeting cards
um
and i go home at christmas
to back to shropshire and my parents
friends would say
so you do something with greeting cards
is that something you do
from your spare room yeah anyway very
very very i mean having because i'd run
quite a big business in russia and and
then of course it started it turned into
something serious um
so it was an interesting challenge which
is how do you sort of reinvent yourself
after that and i i i actually stopped i
went into the charity sector um
full-time and i became a ceo of a
children's charity for uh
for a year full time and then i became a
trustee of that for another four years
why um
well partly because i think i i'd
i think i sort of satisfied i felt as
i'd satisfied everything that i needed
to you know i didn't want any more stuff
so i wasn't
it was it was going to be hard to get
motivated just by making more money um
so so i wanted to have
i wanted to make sure whatever i did
after that was useful so socially useful
in some respect but for that you've got
to kind of do the work you've got to
understand
how to make a how to make a difference
and
and that first year really made me
realize how complicated it is and how
difficult it is to make a to make a real
difference um in the world um
uh so it's fascinating um and and i
wouldn't have been able to do that if i
hadn't if i hadn't sold the company i
wouldn't have the freedom to go off and
and and do that it's not interesting
that people they typically it's this is
a super like generalization and it's not
necessarily the truth but it appears
that we all start quite selfish in life
it's like let me get rich and free first
and then you see that transition when
people do make money is their joy comes
from philanthropy and helping others
i think but i think
you know in that very privileged
position of of
having seen what it's like afterwards
because of course for most people they
they want more things
i think
money a lack of financial problems can
bring you happiness not having financial
problems financial problems brings you
misery when you're beyond financial
problems um
you're neutral and then there's and then
there's and then there's financial
freedom which is i'm now free i don't
have to do the nine-to-five job
i have the option if i want to do to do
other things beyond that pretty i'd say
it's pretty diminishing marginal returns
i mean i think for some people
the more money they make it's about it's
not about the money itself it's more
about uh their position in our you know
you know if you're very competitive as a
hierarchy of people and there's someone
up there who's you know who's made
jeff bezos up there
and they see themselves on that
trajectory they'll never quite be happy
until they're up there and they'll never
get there so yeah um
i i realized very early on that if you
if that i wanted to avoid getting into
that
into that sort of competitive mindset of
thinking that i have to be somewhere on
that trajectory i've kind of you know
satisfied what i what i need in terms of
in terms of
you know stuff housing and whatever um
and then thereafter it's about being
free to explore other things one of the
things i noticed about you that's like
very different to the other um
successful people that i've talked to
and we touched on that a little bit was
you and we talked about a little bit
earlier but my question is i'm slightly
related um is
there seems to be a lot of like neurotic
obsession with people's
businesses hobbies i mean i remember
sitting with eddie hearn here and him
telling me how like how i mean his book
is called relentless like how relentless
he is and to the point where he will
sacrifice his family
to for the business and he'll tell him
he'll speak to have the conversation
with his wife and say my business is
everything if i you know don't make the
date if i don't make this then it is
what it is i am obsessed
um you don't seem to be like that
and that makes one would then therefore
assume
that
the problem that sometimes comes with
being like that which is a severe
cost to sort of relationships
wouldn't be present in you
i think you can be driven by two things
you can be driven by demons or driven by
passion
and it's much better to be driven by
passion than demons yeah some people are
some some people were offended at the
age of 11 by a comment that somebody
made to them that they'll never amount
to anything
and they have struggled ever since to
prove to that person that a teacher said
something bad to them and then finally
they go back sort of 35 years they go
back to school and and and they find
this old teacher who says well i always
thought you'd make something of yourself
and they think
[ __ ] i was hoping it's going to be more
gratifying
it was it was
you know the teacher might just say i
just felt you needed a bit of a kick um
to get yourself off you and it worked
didn't it um so um
some people are driven by
and the people who driven by demons are
often it doesn't make them happy like an
itch they're scratching and it just
makes it makes it worse amen eddie hands
basically like that and he he was quite
honest about that his dad basically he
was always trying to live up to his
dad's expectations of him
and i remember saying to him i remember
saying to eddie i was you know what's
the goal then eddie well you know we're
gonna sell it for five billion yeah and
then what
and then he's like well you know then i
you know i'll have my cigar and i'll go
to the beach do you actually think you'd
go to the beach cigar you just told me
you're obsessive and right and he goes
probably not probably probably
and actually the difficult thing is then
what do you do afterwards i think
because
i think it's one thing a lot of people
they think a business of starting a
business is about you start a business
and then you're working towards an exit
and happiness comes and exit it doesn't
happiness comes from the process of
building a business and working with
people and pulling together bright
people watching the work and creating
this thing i love the learning process i
think that's perhaps one of the other
things that i learned out of all of this
is that
i really really enjoy learning
and it doesn't matter how much money
you've got you can't learn japanese any
quicker but you can learn a little bit
quicker if you've got some really good
but basically you've got to put the work
in doesn't matter how rich you are you
can't buy that you've actually got to
put the work in that drives you so do
you think you're a balanced person i'm
trying to get i'll be honest what i'm
trying to understand here is
a lot of the entrepreneurs that i meet
that the reason why they're successful
is because of as you say you described
it perfectly because of demons or
something yeah and then that costs them
somewhere else yeah you seem to be as
was the case with the um the ceo of
delivery who sat here a couple weeks ago
fairly balanced person so i'm assuming
then you have really well-balanced
relationships
i think i got great friends and great
great friends and great relationships
and and a lovely family and um
um but but that's partly comes down to
it and part of it comes down to standing
back and thinking you know what is
success and i look at success that more
rounded thing what makes you a
successful human being
and and if you look at that then you're
constantly looking you're constantly
measuring yourself by well like actually
what do my friends think of me what do i
think i'm a good person am i a good
person i think i'm a good person um how
am i going to look look back at my life
and be embarrassed at the way that i've
trodden on people on the way up and and
and in which case you know don't tread
on people on the way up
so it depends on what you regard as
success what you define as success in
the beginning i think unfortunately we
too often we measure the things that are
easiest to measure and the easiest thing
to measure is how wealthy someone is um
so
when i go back to talk to talk at
schools about about all my old school
about about and you're invited along
presumably because everyone's heard of a
business that you've created i i'm
reluctant to create this illusion that
that you know if you work incredibly
hard you can make a lot of money and
that will make you successful you have
to be a successful human being
what is a successful human being well i
think it's all the you know those things
that one you've got to be you've got to
be a good citizen you've got to make
your fair contra you've got to make a
good contribution to society now if
you're good at business um you are of
course helping to pay a lot of the bills
which is a great thing um if you pay
your taxes properly but the um
but but but equally it's about the way
that you treat your employees it's about
the way that you treat the people around
you um and
all of those things i think the things
that you look back on your own life and
you think did i did i lead a good life
um was i was i was i a good person um or
do i regret look back and think you know
i was a bit harsh
quick one as a serial entrepreneur
that's currently building multiple
projects across multiple industries
everything from the marketing industry
to blockchain to consumer goods
everything one of the things that has
been a lifesaver for me and again a
company that i reached out to to
evangelize about on this podcast because
i'm a loyal customer and they ultimately
ended up sponsoring this podcast is
fiverr.com
f-i-v-e-r-r what that site allows me to
do is extend my capacity
across all of my projects if i'm looking
for a graphic designer someone to edit a
video someone to do a website for me it
allows me to extend my capacity without
hiring people and the quality of
freelancers on fiverr has been amazing
and when the trust and the service you
get is that phenomenal and the services
often offered are that diverse it's a
no-brainer whether you have one member
of staff you're a freelancer yourself or
a thousand members of staff five it can
be a game changer for you and i'd love
you guys to check it out use the link
below go to fiverr.com
and send me a screenshot if you end up
using the service one of you is going to
win something very amazing
as you look ahead in you know the next
chapter of your life yeah we talked you
talked there about how the journey is
actually there where all the fun and
fulfillment lives yeah um and you kind
of like because i think we all kind of
like mentally map out what the next
phase of our life will look like we
don't necessarily know the details that
have a business plan but we understand
like the the fundamentals of that phase
what what are you what are you hoping
will be
part of that phase um
at the stage of life you're at where
money isn't you know money isn't gonna
mean that you can can or can't eat um
what are you trying to put into that
chapter of your life well um the other
thing i've realized um and i i listened
to something bill gates said which is
that if bill gates had become a doctor
he could have affected quite a few
people's lives but by going into
business he affected millions of
people's lives and he was very good at
making money and so i don't see anything
wrong with pursuing i mean now
i'm actively pursuing the businesses
that i that i'm involved with and i
would love to make more money but then
that gives me the freedom to do
something useful with that money it as a
whole other dimension to why are you
doing it i mean i'm chasing because i
need another lamborghini
because i've got a very old battered
discovery and a lamborghini
it's just not what i was going to say i
can imagine you're in a landfill no no
i'm just a very very tired old discovery
which i'm driving into the ground before
i buy an electric car but there's got to
be a reason for doing it and and you
know the reason
the reason for creating companies partly
because it is it is good fun i mean i
you know
thoroughly enjoy you have an idea and
you're creating something um
and
uh
if seeing your idea come play out and
you think yeah i was right that that
hypothesis was right so we pull together
some good people and it starts to work
and then 10 10 years later
absolutely that that that worked and
we've got a whole lot of people in
employment they're enjoying themselves
and the great thing also is when you
step back from that and you think that
that thing i mean moon pig has a life
its own i was in the car the other day
and there was a moon being advert came
on the radio
i've been i've been out of that for a
long time now i haven't been involved
you know haven't worked there for 10
years and and yet that's
it sort of carried on without me um
there's a huge sense of pride in that
when you see that it must be surely yeah
and actually you know when you sell a
business it's also a sense of pride that
it worked for them as well i think the
very best deals are deals where both
parties came away happy will you ever be
a ceo again
i don't know that i will because
i enjoy i enjoy the sort of that being
having the freedom to do different
things um and
there are plus and minuses to have this
this plural life um
i've realized that having doing 10 of 10
things is twice as much work as doing
100 of one thing
um
twice as much work definitely twice too
much work but partly from a very simple
perspective is the is the um i mean
nesso now post covered but before that
they actually simply they're getting
from one place to the other oh yeah you
know and that that gets in the way of
things um
but also it's the constant juggling in
your head and
and and that and then suddenly you think
oh i've been focused on that for a bit
and it's it's more work um so i would
like to be more focused i want to get
interested at a level where i feel as
i'm able to make a positive difference
to it um and that means that means
actually a smaller number of a smaller
number of things i had a job when i was
at university and the most boring job
ever it was a it was transcribing
license details it was working for a
ford dealership transcribing license
details from one ledger to another
and i'd get to about 10 o'clock in the
morning
physically it was it was so boring it
was physically painful and i would i
would i would think surely it must be
five o'clock it's not it's still ten
o'clock in the morning and it was
horrible absolutely horrible and and the
one thing i look back at my life but
it's one of the the greatest things is
i've never i've always got to five
o'clock wishing it was two o'clock
um and uh and that's that's i think a
sign that that you're not bored um
and there's the stuff i'd like to be
doing like i look for i wake up on
monday morning i think fantastic i can
get stuck in and i can do stuff and so
but that idea of that idea of of
there not being enough hours to do to to
get the stuff done is is a sign that
it's enjoyable the ones that don't like
what they do you know because i've
worked jobs outside call center night
shifts for you know just pick up the
phone book the hotel for them because
they can figure out how to use the
computer yeah yeah you know for dorothy
yeah she doesn't know where she wants to
stay she wants to stay in manchester
doesn't know where manchester you know
night shifts of doing stuff like that
i've had worse jobs as well where i had
to open the yellow pages and just call
someone and try and sell them something
um which was awful um but what is that
what liberates people from that place i
i mean i would maybe guess that it's
information and maybe skills so maybe
they could
the other thing is when you've got one
of those jobs
you take the view look i've got an
opportunity to learn how this to learn
how this works if i learn how this does
work works but take it seriously do it
well um then
actually i might know what it takes to
become a supervisor um if you become a
supervisor i might have then what it
takes to go up to to go one notch higher
and suddenly i'm actually then managing
people and and and that's a little bit
more interesting than what i was doing
so to some extent you have the control
to be able to sign how much time and
effort enthusiasm you put into it and
there's some jobs that will not be that
interesting but then then then say to
yourself right what can i learn about
doing doing this that's going to enable
me just to do my bosses job um and and
actually what your employers will be
looking for is someone who's applied
who's interested and they'll look
amongst the 10 people who are doing that
job and think nine out of 10 of those
people are just doing this because they
want to pay the bills this one is
genuinely trying to work out how to do
the job better
i've got one last question for you yeah
never asked this question before but but
it feels like i should you're you know
you're you know several years ahead of
me in business right so you've
experienced a lot more than me you've
had a child you've gone through you know
even dragon's den you've been through
that experience as well and had a taste
of all of that you know um attention
and um
uh
press and all that stuff
what would be the one piece of advice
you'd give to me
it can be relating to anything it's just
you you know maybe what's something that
you think
i need to learn or know based on me
being on 20 you know 28 29 now
i think i've just left my companies just
hold my shares a little bit yeah um
as you go as you go through
you can get to a point where you think
right i've had a huge success and i look
at moonpick and think will i ever have a
success as big as moonpig i don't know i
don't know but i've got to be okay with
that
and in order to be happy i have to be i
have to be okay with the idea that i may
never i may never better that
because if if you're always constantly
thinking right i've done that i
therefore have to do that it can be
recipe for misery and like
like you look at pop stars who who have
a huge career and then
and they're kind of done by 25 and
actually you know you know that they're
not going to quite come back and and
then a couple years later
and and so i look at it and i think well
i don't have to better what i did in
terms of i don't i'm not going to judge
myself by having a business that was
worth more than moonpig because actually
that's setting myself on almost
impossible task what i'm going to do is
make sure that whatever i do i feel as
though i was being
i feel as it was useful
um and some of this might not be as
obvious or as prominent as
setting up moon pig because sometimes
you catch a wave and i look at moon pig
and i think
did i just catch a wave i was in the
right place at the right time i i had a
good idea and i managed it well but
actually i had it you know i just caught
that wave perfectly and sometimes you
that that that can be hard to break to
to to recreate
um so
so i think being
managing your own expectations is uh is
is is a
uh is an important part of human
happiness um and and thinking okay i may
never better that but actually i'm gonna
do something different now and that will
be just as interesting it'll be just as
rewarding as as as as
as what i did before do you ever regret
so like with with my company um i think
i left in 2019 when the valuation was
maybe 200 million i think now it's like
500 yeah and it's probably going to go i
shouldn't
i'm guessing here okay i'm not involved
in the company anymore i'm probably
going to go to a billion i reckon yeah
um
do you ever regret moon pig is now worth
what one point something
1.1.6 well i i for for a long time i
said eight years after i saw the when i
sold the business it was making about 11
12 million pounds profit
not not ebitda proper profit like money
you could spend um and um
and eight years later it was making
about 18 million so i think yeah it was
an improvement on where on on where it
was but it wasn't so spectacular that it
was um so that they're happy with their
deal uh and i'm happy that i've got the
chance to go off and do something else
um and then i looked at floating and
think well because the thing about
floating is that nobody knew we were
going to have covered and and um and
that obviously massively boost uh
boosted the business and i think
property has permanently put more people
on online so that was a fairly
unpredictable uh part of it then there's
another question which is if i had
stayed in running that business would it
have done as well as it has and i don't
know that it would have done to be if
i'm really honest because the guys who
came afterwards a guy called stan ron
who came into moon big after me um who
was
awesome i mean he was a you know
brilliant um and then and then and that
then nicole rytha who's running it now
is has just taken it to another level so
we're going to take where he came in and
he's just so and
so so i i i'm not sure that i would have
done i'm not sure had i stayed in
there's no guarantee that it would have
done what it what it did and in fact
i'm not sure it would have done
so you know i and actually i've had some
done some really interesting things so
if you're asking me the question would i
rather have had sort of 36 percent of
1.6 billion yes
what i'm questioning is whether we would
have got there if i'd remain in the helm
well listen nick thank you so much for
your time it's been an incredibly
interesting diverse conversation and
yeah um thank you as well for uh you
sent a text message i think to
our mutual friend before i went on the
show just giving me oh yeah
yeah and he passed that over to me and i
i yeah i kept that in mind i won't show
what that advice was
i kept that in mind and um yeah i mean
your story is super inspiring and
there's a british success story and
someone that's so
i'm so fascinated by you because you're
so unorthodox in so many ways and you
also don't [ __ ] so a lot of people
it's tempting to portray yourself even
with the last example there you could
have said well you know you basically
said that you're you're unsure whether
the business would have performed better
or worse without you i think that takes
great humility and self-awareness to
admit that and that's the reason why i
started this podcast because you know to
share some of that honesty with the
world so thank you for coming on thank
you for being an inspiration to me thank
you for being one of my favorite dragons
as well you're just very real and funny
thank you it's good to have a real sense
of humor well it's been a real it's been
a real pleasure meeting him in person so
um brilliant superb and um yeah
hopefully we'll get you back again once
uh to talk more about your charity in
particular which i wish we had more time
to yeah to talk about because that's
that was super inspiring to read about
as well
um but yeah thank you thanks nick great
[Music]
you